[Music]
hello and welcome to the second of our
special editions of the sky news daily
podcast with me dermot mernahan now uh a
dozen of our correspondents are joining
me over three episodes in total to
reflect on some of the the big the
momentous stories of 2021. so over the
next half an hour in this podcast we'll
be discussing themes surrounding global
security the migrant crisis and politics
and as ever to discuss it all i have a
panel of sky news's very best and
biggest experts are political editor
beth rigby dominic waghorn our
international affairs editor along with
sky correspondent ashna harinag joining
us remotely our special correspondent
alex crawford and europe correspondent
adam parsons welcome to you all well
what a lot we've got to discuss up first
uh let's take you through some of the
biggest global stories of the year
i will be a president for all americans
multiple capital entries
49 hours declaring it right i think it's
a procession of of the taliban yes it is
there's the white flag these 20 years
have felt like both a long time and a
short time this house has lost a
steadfast servant the title of the
report is china's elite capture i think
russia itself is moving from being an
authoritarian state to being a much more
totalitarian state
well a flavor just a flavor of what's
been going on in this momentous year
dominick we should of course start with
you and there's a kind of thread running
through the biden presidency this time a
year ago as we heard there he was
president elect well in most people's
minds uh not in the in the sitting
presidents of course and even before he
he came to power there was the
extraordinary event in the heart of
washington itself in the heart of global
democracy yeah the event that that
photograph behind you is is showing uh
the assault on the capital and i think
we kind of forget in a way the year
began with that it seems to almost
belong to a different time
after a year of biden in the white house
but it is a crucial event and i think
when
foreign policy students come to study
2021 in the in the coming years there
are two key events obviously the
afghanistan debacle but also of equal
importance is the assault on the capital
because this was america
turning it against itself a sizable
number of americans um desecrating the
holy of holies in washington the high
temple of their democracy goaded on by
their own presidents who was peddling
this grand lie that the election had
been uh stolen
um and uh being helped and facilitated
by social media and the the message to
the world was that this was an america
that was divided riddled with self-doubt
and that is important in terms of our
global security because it has i think
uh undermined the support or the
confidence of allies in america um even
though we have a new president and the
challenge for joe biden was to deal with
that and also to see off enemies and
rivals who've been emboldened not just
by the trump presidency but the coda the
spectacular code that ended it and and
his promise biden was to
to bring back america america is back he
said taking its rightful place in his
mind as leader of the free world
and um enforcing the pax americana after
the four years he would regard an
aberration america is back
alex uh talked to us about as uh dominic
called it and he wouldn't have been the
first the debacle of the withdrawal from
afghanistan and of course britain
intimately involved
what a shameful episode
of history actually international
history that whole
period was still now i'm getting emails
and phone calls from people that we
interviewed
doctors health workers in the hospitals
female rights activists who showed me
pictures of them side by side with laura
bush
the former first lady working with the
british military arm and armed with
british soldiers american soldiers
all sorts of international workers who
now won't pick up the phone to them and
won't won't help them and they're still
ringing me and texting my producer and
my team saying please help us out please
get us out i'm a journalist like you can
you somehow get us out the taliban are
knocking on our door the taliban's
beaten my brother the talibans killed my
aunt please come and help us so it's
very difficult to have been involved in
that story very difficult to have um
stood in in afghanistan or in kabul and
talk to these people and say you know
those 20 years that you spent working
side by side where you thought the
future was different the future was
going to be bright and the your
international partners were going to
stand side by side with you it's very
difficult to look them in the eye right
now and say yeah they kept all their
promises because they very definitely
didn't
and beth rippy i mean from the um from
the british perspective we're talking
there about its involvement in the
withdrawal from afghanistan and in
reality if the americans were going
there's very little
the british could do but but overall i
suppose two questions or two half to the
same question where does britain now see
itself standing in terms of of global
britain that ambition post-brexit and
you know what what is the sense because
you've been to the summits and what is
the sense from from other countries
about britain's standing now it's left
the european union well i think there's
an idealized vision that boris johnson
has of global britain but when it rubs
up with reality it's a rather different
thing indeed and as don was saying in
terms of afghanistan
it was a unilateral decision by the u.s
the uk was blindsided the uk
was scrambling and the ufk in a way
diminished on the world state indeed it
was theresa may the former prime
minister who said in the commons after
that directly to the prime minister to
boris johnson
if the u.s had taken a decision
is global britain
so powerless if you like that it can't
come up with an alternative that it
can't galvanize nato and it was a
question of well actually what does
global britain stand for if you are just
the puppy if you like of the us in that
situation so i think there's one thing
around the bilateral relationship and
it'd be more important to the uk because
of brexit the bilateral relationship
with the us but this being a u.s that is
acting particularly unilaterally when it
comes to decisions it's taken because
the reality is that on a global stage
brexit has diminished the uk in that
it's no longer part of the european
gangs so that biden might look to france
or germany to negotiate with that block
rather than using that transatlantic
bridge that was once the uk
and ashland in terms of global issues
the one that has never gone away and
isn't going away but all eyes have been
on on other things over the last year
but terror and we've seen terror attacks
alleged terror attacks taking place on
uk soil this year yeah i mean the tragic
killing of um sir david amis mp and down
in south end on sea um was i i suppose
the shock of it um having been down i
mean immediately i was sent down there
and um you sort of speak to people on
the ground and
when growing up i don't really know who
my local mp was to be perfectly honest
with you but this was somebody who
everybody knew um on the doorsteps you'd
be talking to people in the community he
was so well loved
everyone could agree from close friends
to charities to
neighbours everyone agreed that they
might not have agreed with his politics
but this was a great man who not only
cared about the national issues but the
local issues who cared about campaigning
about the bus lanes he cam he campaigned
about um you know the high streets in in
this investing and invigorating local
people to put south end on sea on the
map um but it was the brutality of his
death
that everybody
um that shook the whole community and
not only south and on sea but the whole
of the uk as well okay adam i want to
talk to you about uh global issues and
migration of course which we're going to
discuss in another part of the podcast
in more detail when it concerns the
united kingdom but of course when it
concerns the european union and the
world there's there's a big crisis
taking place in the european union's
eastern border and it kind of relates as
well to situations like afghanistan as
we've been discussing as long as those
global debacles keep happening there
will be more migration
yeah this one is uh that this is on the
effectively the border between belarus
uh and largely poland and this one is is
down to alexander lukashenko the the
leader of belarus elected in what i
think we could safely describe as a a
contested election what we might also
describe as a completely fixed election
and what mr lukashenko then did
was to invite
would be refugees largely from uh sort
of a iraq but also you know putting the
net out around the world and saying if
you can get
uh to minsk then i will try to arrange
for you to get to the border and by the
way if you get across the border into
poland you can get to germany which
let's not forget germany takes by far
the number the greatest number of
migrants in the eu a lot more than the
uk let's say it takes
so people flooded into mints got taken
down to the border unsurprisingly poland
decided that this was the last thing it
wanted ditto lithuania ditto latvia and
created this
pretty horrific standoff with humans
being used as bargaining chips and mr
lukashenko knew this he knew it would
cause enormous arguments he knew the eu
would struggle to come up with a
concerted response which it did
in the end i think it took a lot of
pressure from the united states and it
also took some quite clever sanctions
for instance on
not just sanctioning belarus that
they've done that but also threatening
sanctions against airlines that were
knowingly taking people
into minsk okay well that's happening on
the eastern borders of the european
union but uh let's focus now on how
migration is affecting the uk and
relations between the uk and the eu
cross-channel migrants normally operate
in the shadows of night but this is
something profoundly different why did
you risk your life to come across the
channel
because that country
for your life i have already approved
maritime tactics including boat
turnarounds for border force to deploy
15 man overboard approximately 15 man
overboard i think it's rather
regrettable isn't it that the first
thing we wake up to is another blame
game
27 people died on november the 24th we
all remember that ashna you've reported
from the beaches from off the beaches
just just tell us some of what you've
seen your impressions i've seen so many
of those touchdown moments of those
landings on the beaches and
i think lots of people think that they
look like um the people stepping off
those boats are ecstatic that they're
celebratory in reality they're exhausted
they're shocked they're fearful
everything looks different they've spent
months travelling in the most dangerous
way
and then to finally arrive onto the
cobbled
beaches of kent i always wonder
is it what they expected
everything looks different the
landscape's different people aren't
speaking the language they're used to
they've finally made it to britain is
this
is this what they wanted and of course
they get shipped off to various
houses centers across hotels across the
uk
and so begins their refugee or asylum
seeking
process and that can take six months to
two years
and the amount of money they get
it's pennies really it's about 30 pounds
a week
and suddenly they're having to
adapt and integrate
and i do think a lot and when i've
spoken to a lot of them um in in a few
months after they've arrived i spent a
lot of time at the napier barracks in
the surrounding area which is a center
in folkestone where a lot of the young
men
are housed um and they're just they're
almost a bit
deflated because they're faced with a
lot of animosity
from the communities there having said
that there's a huge
charity you know scope i mean refugee
crisis centres are are quite remarkable
in the work that they do
um
but they
they're just they're baffled really also
at the debate in all of this
because they they sort of there's a
sense of frustration they not see why
we're coming over look at our countries
look at our nations it's also not an
ambition that they'll stay here they
just want to work here earn money and
then go back perhaps it's definitely a
divisive issue down in kent
that's really interesting here because
so now we have the opportunity to join
up both ends of these long long journeys
as you describe them there ashley
because of course we've got alex here
with us sue alex of course you've
reported from so so many of the
countries where these journeys begin and
give us your sense of of the why
why people decide to leave the countries
therein there are complex reasons and
also
the role in facilitating that of the of
the people smugglers so called
yeah and i think it's interesting
listening to ashna because they
definitely do it as a very very last
resort
no no one i know of and as you said i've
seen it from the other end where people
are desperately trying to get in touch
with the people smugglers i've spoken to
the people smugglers they they're
they're very very upset about leaving
their homeland they're crying
all they've got is a bag sometimes they
don't even have that they don't all they
have is the clothes they stand on a lot
of them don't even have documents with
them to verify who they are um
it's astonishing to me that i went on
that that journey from turkey to greece
with a whole load of
at that time there were syrians and
libyans iraqis on one of those dinghies
and it was a terrifying experience and
that only lasted a couple of hours
they've already done a huge journey you
know crossing over mountains and um
putting their faith and sometimes all
their money everything they've got in
the hands of
a people smuggler and those people
smugglers can be
a big range of them you know some of
them one of them ones who was a young
man that i was speaking to was doing it
because he felt it was a moral duty to
help them and then you've got the
networks of the mafia ozo types who
don't really care their numbers and
they're just filling the boats and just
sending them on the way you give your
money and whether you get over alive or
not you've lost that money well let's go
to those beaches of northern france
adam's had plenty experience of what
goes on then what doesn't go on and by
that i mean you know the the french
efforts or not to try to to stop some of
those crossings but also touch on the
people smuggling operation there the the
kind of people that are willing to put
these desperate people these desperate
families into you know inflatable
dinghies
so while
every politician on either side of the
channel says we have to clamp down on
people smuggling you have this almost
arms race between the british and the
french about who hates people smugglers
more the reality is these people aren't
aren't going away they are by the way
making an absolute fortune out of this
but every time that i have spoken to
migrants uh in calais or on the northern
french coast they're pretty much
unembarrassed about saying they have to
go to people smugglers they don't think
they have uh any alternative and so you
do end up with with these clusters of
people suddenly appearing a beach now
normally it's happened at night
we had the extraordinary scene a couple
of months ago when we were filming
on the northern french coast we were on
a beach talking to the french police who
were there
and then about 100 meters away from us
dozens of people came running down
carrying an enormous boat
took it down uh to uh to the shore put
it in the water or with the french
police watching uh and then spent ages
trying to start this completely
unsuitable engine in order to begin
their voyage
across the channel so in terms of what
the french police do well in that case
they don't do anything but this is again
is a real source of tension because
you've got again a big political round
with the brits saying well the french
police should be doing a lot more
uh
and we're giving them money and then the
french interior minister joel dominant
said to me well we haven't had any money
and we've spent a lot more the reality
is the french coast is very very long
you'd need an armada frankly to seal
that off
night and day okay well uh dominic alex
and ashna you can all go thank you very
much indeed uh beth adam and i uh next
we're going to discuss more about those
rows over fish and sausages as we look
at political posturing let's call it
that in 2021
[Music]
now then it's not of course just been
the migrant crisis issue causing tension
between the uk and its european
neighbors not by a long chalk one of the
staff members has come out and said no
more petrol it's stupidity that we're
all here enough but this is my job so
i've got to have diesel there's being a
hundred thousand drivers short of what
we need across the uk but the shortages
are being felt right through the food
supply chain imagine if bratwurst could
not be moved from dortmund to dusseldorf
with no more than five hours sleep a
night she's maintained an unlikely grip
on power this is
well let's discuss all that with adam
parsons and beth rigby and uh how did we
talk don't we on previous podcasts about
um
the role of fish in the fishing industry
in this dispute between britain and
france but but just first of all you
know explain for us this psychology from
from the french side about why it's so
important it's presumably as tiny a part
of their economy as it is of the uk's
i think there's a few things at play
here i mean you're right it's a small
part of the uk economy it's a small part
of the french economy but in both
cases it has a symbolic
importance that far outweighs any
financial
impact so for the uk i think this is
about sovereignty it's about controlling
your waters it's about making decisions
about who can come in and who can't uh
for the french similar sort of things
it's also about here we have this
historical precedent our
fishermen have always gone out into
these waters why should they be
constrained now also though uh emmanuel
macron he's got a presidential election
coming up
early next year and he knows that that
region of france
last time round tweeted between him and
marine le pen
uh and he doesn't want that to happen
again he wants to look strong he wants
to look like he is he is a big leader
who is not afraid of taking on uh
battles and that by the way isn't just
about brexit that is a part of emmanuel
macron's great vision of himself
in the absence of angela merkel she's
kind of gone now he sees himself as the
next european leader well uh from fish
let's uh go to sausages sounds like a
children's tea time doesn't it fish
fingers and sausages peas on the side
you've got to eat those up um beth why
are sausages so important and we're
talking here about the northern ireland
protocol yeah the reason sausages are so
important it's about how freely goods
can move between great britain and
northern ireland and sausages
and other
meat products have been the subject of
some
tension should we say between the
european union
and the uk government about how the
protocol
is being implemented i mean is it going
to get sorted i mean you know the key
question people want to know is well we
thought this was done and dusted
actually this time last year just before
christmas that's all sorted out now
boris johnson two christmases ago so had
an election and said you know we've got
an oven ready deal we've signed it off
why are they still negotiating because
the uk would argue
that the protocol does not work and they
need to look at it again that it's not
working
and it's important for the sovereignty
and integrity of great britain and the
united kingdom and the european union
would argue well hang on a minute you
signed the deal you knew the terms of
the deal
we will negotiate details of the
implementation but we are not
ripping up this agreement and starting
again which is what the uk government
would like to happen so there is a
stalemate at the moment okay adam
parsons beth rigby brilliant talking to
you both and uh just let me remind you
that all of these special sky news daily
podcasts with me dermot manhattan are
available on demand wherever you get
your podcasts or videos from now our
next podcast we're going to be
discussing climate change the royals and
space quite a mixed bag this edition was
produced by annie joyce along with felix
forbes thank you very much indeed for
listening
[Music]